walk into this video playing on the
rough let's get rid of this bloody
window Omer off from Turkey and okay get
them get the Dutch and I'm trying this
Bishop f4 line but I still feel that I'm
playing it wrong very often i'm just
playing it wrong don't get good
positions from it yeah with setups like
this people seem to know that seems to
be a good setup yeah I really must look
this up this type of position is really
not very satisfactory like getting an
even five now at least most of the time
they get any five not sure about here
maybe it's even possible here i take i
hear complete you fora or not Jiggs yeah
if I I really want to play that if I if
given the chance
oh just like that you're not the
structure amazing here maybe it's active
enough to to compensate each other's
weaknesses maybe a g6 e6 or weekend but
still how do you how do you exploit it i
canti to retreat the bishop first
maybe we can get active play with stuff
like c5 why a five maybe c 3 is pitaya
c3 was button getting the bishop to see
too that's a good idea anyway maybe get
the bishop to see you then possibly
queen form hmm yay force I was played a
bit too quickly
yeah trying to pressure rise g6 that's
really the weakest pawn it is interested
in this position
so he wants to go what 97 after Queenie
for or I please you five something like
that maybe you ok I'm going to get the
King out of this
Queen d3 next gym
23 why is he just taking the pawn then
be three it's not a move I like to play
very much
hmm
ok let's try to block the upon it's very
very essential yeah my king position is
really not not really is very much
confidence
we have seven probably could be five at
least I'm not far behind on the clock
mark keep it keep it protected at the
moment and maybe I need some moves to to
consolidate me a cookie one
trying to keep this blockade one year
for if he manages to somehow push the
epon then his Bishop on g7 will change
from from being quite quite bad to two
very strong against my king at least
he's taking taking time I could be a
kiss could be a good mover threatening
to take all your fault and takes rook
takes is very bad
it's not not easy at all
takes rook chicks I do I don't see
something great for him but I feel that
there is something my position looks
shaky it really does check maybe it's
maybe even that is working at least I
don't need to spend any time I must take
ok so here don't have many many other
squares I don't I don't feel that this
was the what's the refutation
a five
if it takes with with the pawn I take
the coin we attack I takes both the rook
okay could have taken on see form should
be 50 this will be 5 time warning yeah
I'd seen this little tricky to get the
Queen's Own Jack that's that's helpful
black resign yeah okay yeah this was a
very shaky very shaky position I the I
think where I really made a mistake was
here I must place you free this is this
is really better I get the I get a
comparable very comparable position to
the game but without having the
queenside weekend so so immensely
something like that maybe am I know my
king is much safer and there is less
counter play the position is maybe okay
Ferb like it looks it looks very him
yeah it's not very pleasing to the eye
the structure a 5 g 6 h-6 but I Scott
activity this is fairly active and I
don't have a clear way to June to block
on your form Scott get this that's very
possible for black turnout yet it got
got very shaky maybe it was the idea to
Castle long maybe he was wrong okay a
comp wants to play h5 here didn't didn't
consider this
yeah it's really interesting I really
felt that I have problems the computer
is giving me a clear advantage after c4
I know it gets lower okay i was sad i
cannot really think that why should be
yeah better at all let alone clearly but
i-- i know it goes down to equal and
yeah this was a strong move Bishop g5
also here felt from the magic jack yeah
this was wrong yeah the comp just once i
check oops sorry wants to take and go
here with this young okay yeah and here
we see the big problem if he gets in
this and the e porn moves to to free the
g7 bishop then my position is probably a
crumbling quickly i need to do this and
maybe here yeah this is good for luck no
doubt about it he gets he gets the
position open against my king okay so
check this wasn't the way to go but he
had very little time so so it's clear
that they're they're bound to be
mistakes made yeah this was was nice
that I get got the material of him okay
thanks for watching